all right welcome everybody because
jensaki is still in the press briefing
we're going to get to it um we'll see if
the stuff about the vaccine mandates
coming up let's listen then we'll get to
everything else to we will leave it to
and we'll work lot in lockstep with him
leader schumer to determine what this
next steps are here and i know he's
spoken a bit to that but ultimately um
this is about continuing to press to
move forward on the protection of voting
rights and to use it as a moment to
elevate this issue as an important issue
for people across the country
and of course any senator is going to be
put in the position of determining what
side of history they're going to stand
on and that's i guess the purpose of a
vote the president also spoke about
voter subversion when he spoke to
reporters but neither the freedom to
vote act nor the john lewis voting
rights act
deal with subversion focus more on
suppression
would the president want to see
democrats if this process does move
forward in the future address
uh
laws in in these 19 states some of which
would potentially allow for the
overturning of a free fair election well
the john lewis voting rights act um
actually in section 112 actually makes
it illegal for state officials to
willfully fair or fail or refuse to
certify the aggregate tabulations of
votes or certify the election of the
candidates receiving sufficient such
votes to be elected to office that is
obviously addressing a root problem
we're seeing in laws in many states
across the country and what these laws
are meant to do is provide some
fundamental baselines for protections
for voters and that's an important part
of doing it obviously there's more you
will continue to build from there but
that's an important component i think
that uh sometimes everyone isn't always
aware of in the john lewis voting rights
act
oh good one has anyone been watching
long enough to know if they've asked
questions about the vaccine mandate
being blocked chairman uh someone who
has expressed support for postmaster
general lewis to joy who as you know is
that a very controversial tenure what's
what's the white house position on the
persistent delivery delays that the
postal service seems to be experiencing
at least anecdotally and uh dejoy's
current place
as postmaster general does he deserve to
have that role you know i love anecdotal
data i will tell you that going back to
the holidays uh 97 or 98 percent of
packages from the postal service were
delivered on time so there may be
anecdotes from that one or two percent
but those are that's actual data
across the country uh we have expressed
concerns in the past about delays
leadership that i'm delay sorry to joy
that was a little slip there dejoy's
leadership um in the past uh that has
not changed i will say though and i know
this has been raised i'm just going to
use an opportunity to address it that
that many members of the postal service
including
leadership has expressed confidence and
an interest in playing the role in
delivering tests to people across the
country and their confidence in doing
exactly that uh so we take them at their
word and
certainly we're encouraged by the data
we saw from december
go ahead
oh april let me first say 25 years
covering the white house that's pretty
significant
wow i don't have a song for this but
just congratulations
i mean i'm a terrible singer so we don't
want that anyway go ahead
don't give me an interview
on the record right right um
on another issue jen um
the issue of policing as you're working
on voting rights we understand
simultaneously you know working
diligently on this executive order to
bring more teeth into
protections
for people americans particularly
minorities who are
dying at the hands of
policing
what is different
with this
executive order versus
what could have happened on capitol hill
we understand laws have more teeth but i
understand that you guys are working to
bring more teeth into these executive
orders talk to me about that
it's a great question april and as you
know from covering this closely we we
were kind of waiting on any executive
orders um out of the out of uh deference
to the negotiations that were happening
in a bipartisan manner and of course we
believe that
the ability especially in a bipartisan
way when possible to move forward on
legislation makes it permanent right um
and that is not the case of course uh
with executive orders in terms of the
specific details there are they are
under discussion i just don't have
anything i can outline for you at this
moment because there's an internal
policy discussion i understand there's a
sense of urgency on it i was told
from one source it was days
and then others said it could be weeks
but it's happening soon why the sense of
urgency right now especially when you're
dealing with voting rights trying to
figure that out as well
you know i think there's a recognition
and a commitment uh by the president um
to yeah i will look for a feed that
shows the uh that shows the reporters
standby efforts uh to negotiate police
reform on a bipartisan level obviously
that didn't move forward as we would
have hoped um and so uh there's there's
a there's a legal policy substantive
process that has policy consideration of
executive orders that's ongoing it is
hard to predict the timing of that so i
don't want to do that from here but it's
a it's a it's a reflection of the
president's commitment to delivering on
his promise pbs doesn't seem to when
candidate or president-elect i guess she
would say joe biden was building his
cabinet he specifically singled out
martial fudge for her work and the fact
that she was one of the presidents of
delta sigma theta sorority incorporated
that is having its founders day he
talked about the great work that the
sorority does
um what does he have for the delta
sorority delta sigma theta sorority
incorporated
today as they are celebrating founders
nobody seems to today
of course um well the president wishes
the women of delta sigma theta sorority
incorporated a happy 109th founder's day
and many more years of academic
excellence and service to those
who are members
the president has been very vocal of his
support as you noted april for delta
sigma theta and all divine nine
sororities and fraternities in october
vice president harris hosted a historic
meeting of the divine nine councils of
council of presidents at the white house
which included immediate past president
uh beverly smith and we're incredibly
grateful to the work he is
delta sigma theta has done to uplift
communities across the world especially
the hard work of former national
president and current hud secretary
marcia fudge and the women of delta
sigma theta who work on behalf of the
american people in the biden harris
administration each and every day of
which i hear there are a few go ahead
thank you so much also a one-way
one-year kind of question
when you listen to the president's
inauguration address you hear the words
unity you hear uh below angels of
america we didn't hear these words in
his speeches at the capitol or in
georgia does it mean that he has changed
his state of mind and does he think that
america can't be unifying anymore
no actually quite the contrary i mean
the president believes that protecting
people's fundamental rights to vote and
participate in the process whether
you're a democrat a republican an
independent whatever party uh you are a
member of um that that is not a partisan
issue uh it should be a unifying issue
and and that is why he reflected when he
went to the caucus today on the fact
that there are 16 republicans who have
supported voting rights in the past
because it is not been historically uh a
uh a partisan issue and he's not
prejudging who people support he is
trying to protect people's ability to
participate in the
with the process as it is with the
supreme court as it is uh what's the way
forward for the rest of the mandate is
it more executive orders right smaller
steps rather than you know big
transformative reforms what's you know
what's the idea well that's a big
question um but i would say i would say
that um
the president has had we we feel we've
had a lot of success over the past year
um getting the economy back on stronger
footing
getting 200 million americans vaccinated
getting a bipartisan infrastructure bill
passed rebuilding our relationships in
the world and america standing in the
world and what we want to do now is
build on that in year two that means
continuing to press to get voting rights
done to get bill back better done
there are to get chips funding passed so
we can ensure that manufacturing happens
in the united states so of course there
are still big bold pieces of the
president's agenda he wants to get done
and he's going to keep fighting for it
it is also true that it is challenging
to move things forward with such a small
margin uh in uh in congress and he is
very well aware of that we've been
living it for almost a year now
go ahead and test some questions and a
couple from about cool colleagues who
sure be here the president mentioned the
other 500 million
tests
can you give us any sense on timeline
when you're looking at contracts good
question
when people will actually
end up seeing them after they see this
first half billion sure so um i had said
earlier this week that we were looking
to finalize our uh contracts for the
first 500 million within the two weeks i
can give you an update that now we're at
the point where we've procured about 380
million uh of those tests and we're
going to continue to build from there so
the plan is to um you know we feel we're
making very strong progress of course
and after we conclude this phase will
begin awarding contracts for today's
announcement we'll continue to proceed
from there looking at that very strongly
ballpark on when that that that second
half billion might not yet we we may be
able to as as we kind of proceed in the
process as we have done with the first
500 million but i don't have a specific
update yet at this point in time just a
status update in the first 500 million
and obviously when we uh make when we
conclude this phase we'll move to the
next 500 million you mentioned earlier
in the briefing that less than ten
percent of the population is now having
trouble finding a test can it kind of
said there was a recent poll i'm happy
to tweet it after the briefing if you'd
like to make it available to all of you
i think it was you i would question that
poll we know what you love
but people talking about the long waits
it's like how many people are even
looking for tests
the president made it a point to say
testing has gotten so much better today
but
that would be pretty stark if it's now
one in ten americans claiming that
they're i said a recent poll uh which i
think is just important to know because
um obviously what we we've been doing to
date and where we are at this point in
time is 300 million tests uh every
single month that is a lot of tests and
sometimes
you would think that no one is able to
get a test and no one is being tested
when nearly 12 million people are being
tested every day at the same time as i
have said as the president has said we
want to do more and we are continuing to
do more and that's why we're running
this expedited process to procure more
tests to ensure they're free they're
accessible and they're available to
people across the country
oh good radio pool colleagues okay if
you will
the fba ground stop earlier this week
yeah on the heels of the north korean
missile test can you give us an idea
what information you all have about that
and
is there a fear that these yes
north korean tests may actually pose
some type of danger or issue for u.s
civil aviation i believe the faa has
spoken to this and uh taken kind of a
look back at what happened i think it
was a 15-minute ground stop and they
have reflected on the procedures that
happened and taken a look for them
moving forward i would note that our
national security and most importantly
are defense officials across the country
after those tests conveyed that no
officials were at risk so i'd really
point you to the faa as they assess
that that decision last week or earlier
this week sorry yeah go ahead well uh
a committee to protect journalists
report
questioning saying freedom advocates are
concerned with your administration in
terms of access to the president for
reporters the concept of freedom
advocate is a funny one timely responses
from our press office from the press
office to surprise
two various queries on various topics
two queries okay slow responses to
requests for information let me know
okay from that uh
the request extra night julian assange
restrictions on access to the media uh
at the southern border limited help for
afghan journalists can you give us a
comment from your perspective on on how
you see those things playing out and
what some of these criticisms are well i
haven't read the report but well i would
say broadly speaking that uh when i
spoke with the president about this job
i mean one of our one of the things he
conveyed to me very clearly was
resetting the tone with the media was a
big priority for him and ensuring that
there was a respect even when there's a
point of contention or a difficult
conversation or back and forth that that
is part of democracy but our objective
is to
has been to
reinstill normalcy and engagement with
reporters whether we agree or disagree
whether there is a partisan tilt to an
outlet or not and i think we have
conducted ourselves accordingly and
always we're working to continue to be
responsive i would say i i would say two
inquiries of probably tens of thousands
if not more does not to me sound like a
data point but i will look closer at the
report the other thing i would say is
that um you know the president has taken
questions at about 200 on about 250
occasions
over the past year if you average about
three questions per time that's about
750 questions he's taken that does not
include the formal press conference he
did in march other press conferences
he's done that's about three so let's
say a thousand just to be generous there
that's about three questions a day i
think the american people have seen him
out there answering questions he will
continue to be that's an important part
of his engagement with the press and the
public
and that will be a part of how we
continue to conduct ourselves go ahead
james
thank you very much jim
thank
you i want to ask one on the economy and
one on the pandemic if you don't sure
uh on the economy in yesterday's
briefing with mr diese and in today's
briefing uh you have both cited
economic metrics
uh that showed great progress across
2021 uh from the unemployment rate
uh to job creation to a rise in real
household income and when citing the
progress in those areas both you and mr
dees
attributed
that progress to specific administration
policies
and legislative initiatives
yet when it came to uh the highest
inflation in 40 years
both you and mr diese attributed this to
a variety of external factors
from the pandemic to supply chain
constraints to inaction by the congress
on buildback better
so
to be clear yeah for the american people
in this midterm year who are going to be
assessing the performance of the
president and his party
where specifically inflation is
concerned
does the buck stop with the president
elementary
i would say james first that the
president has spoken to the fact that
costs for americans and the squeeze it
puts on americans is a top concern for
him and i think brian dees also conveyed
that yesterday and that's why uh he put
in place a supply chain task force why
we've prioritized taking steps including
having a port czar including ensuring
there are more truckers on the roads to
ensure there are more goods moving and
more goods on the shelves and we've made
a lot of progress in that regard of
course that's his responsibility and the
responsibility of the economic team i
also think it's notable that if you go
back to earlier this year there were not
the projections of the economic growth
we have seen or the decrease in the
unemployment rate we have seen and that
is in part not just according to us but
many outside economists to the
bills that have passed some of them
bipartisan uh in uh and the work of this
administration to get the economy up and
going again and address covet so your
answer is yes he owns the job creation
he owns the low unemployment rate and he
also owns inflation correct i think any
president should own everything
happening in the country and the
president certainly sees it that way
the president's remarks this morning
included yet another exhortation to the
unvaccinated population to get
vaccinated
he has since assuming office made
dozens and dozens perhaps hundreds of
these kinds of appeals to that
particular population
do you have any evidence
indeed do you have any sound basis
for determining at all
whether he is having any success
in um urging that population to do as he
counsels there are questions we do
if you go back to december of 2020
just over 30 percent maybe 35 percent of
people in this country
was open to getting vaccinated now we're
at the point where more than 80 percent
of the country has gotten at least one
dose what the president also recognizes
is that he's not always the most
effective messenger everybody in the
country is not looking for him to tell
them what to do he certainly knows that
what's most important here is for people
hearing from
local leaders
pediatricians in some cases
doctors
uh people who have different political
beliefs out there uh conveying clear
accurate information about the
effectiveness of these i mean what we
know is it's that mandates are what
really encourage people you know i've
implemented how do we know that 35 of
the american population
uh was willing to get vaccinated a year
ago i can give you the data i'm happy to
give that to you after the briefing it
was a public public poll
go ahead thank you john i have two
questions one in haiti the other one on
canada the first one on haiti yesterday
was the 12th anniversary of the terrible
earthquake of 2010. um
the effects are still being felt over
there uh remembered after that
earthquake when some football analysts
referred to haiti as heisha it's a
really weird clip therefore
the the the migrants that were deported
last fall back the thousands of them
that were that were reported deported
over there
related to the earthquake related to the
earthquake but considering the situation
over there 12 years later
what kind of follow-up has been done
uh with the migrants that were sent back
last fall well we have a very large
presence on the ground a diplomatic
presence on the ground in haiti and that
has continued to be the case we are also
the one of the largest if not the
largest provider of humanitarian
assistance
to haiti through ngos and many outside
groups
in order to provide assistance for the
range of challenges that uh people in
haiti have gone through from uh
earthquakes or natural disasters to
obviously the challenge uh the challenge
of the uh that uh the assassination of
their leader that happened this past
summer so we will continue to be
providers of humanitarian assistance our
diplomatic presence there is on the
ground and working closely with trusted
leaders in the region in the country and
and we will we remain committed to that
the the americans on the ground the
officials on the ground haven't been in
contact with the haitians who have been
deported from texas for instance last
fall
well i i again i would say we have a
diplomatic presence on the ground that's
in touch with a range of haitians who
either have been sent back or who need
help and assistance and we work closely
with local authorities to make sure that
the humanitarian assistance is getting
exactly to the people who need it canada
and jen i just want to check something
with you considering the the the
multiple recent trade setbacks uh with
the us uh yeah the the
uh conservative leader in canada this
week uh claimed that um the u.s canada
relationship is at its lowest point in
decades
how do you see this
we don't see it that way
we
view canada as an important neighbor an
important partner a country we are
aligned on and many democratic values we
work with on a range of issues facing
the global community
and that is certainly the view of our
government here you know frustration
towards for instance the fact that the
buy america
measures are still
imposed actually more strictly under
this administration
we are certainly familiar with the
frustrations of some leaders who were
who have been outspoken about it and
spoke to it when they were here and i
would just reiterate that our objective
here is to make um to make electric
vehicles specifically more accessible to
americans uh to lower the cost here for
americans and that is why uh the
president pushed so hard for those
provisions but we see canada continue to
see canada as an important partner in
the world go ahead on the president's
first anniversary in office um what does
he regard as his single most important
uh there's so many accomplishments
any mistakes have been made and if so
what's the biggest mistake
uh well i would say first that um you
know the president is very proud of the
progress we've made in getting 200
million americans vaccinated very proud
of the work we have done to
cut the childhood poverty by 40 percent
to help americans who needed a little
extra help get by through and
challenging economic time uh the work we
did to get a bipartisan infrastructure
bill passed and to rebuild our place in
the world there are many others i think
uh
confirming nominating confirming
historic judges
across the board
ensuring that our administration up and
down
the ranks looks like america
and i could go on from there fighting to
take steps on climate in a historic
manner that has been more than any
administration in the past uh in terms
of uh in terms of what we look back uh
you know i'm not going to speculate on
that from here i will let the president
speak to that the next time you all see
him did he underestimate donald trump's
continued grip on the republican party
and how difficult that would make it to
work across the aisle and unite the
nation
you know i will tell you that uh hearing
kevin mccarthy talk today for an example
and seeing what he said on january 21st
last year is a pretty stark reminder of
uh how uh how much uh sway the former
president has over members of his party
i think that's disappointing for
everybody not just people who work here
go ahead thank you jen um i wanted to
ask a question from some colleagues who
couldn't be here sure and then and then
before i get to that i wanted to follow
up on a question that justin asked sure
he has like seven questions the
president was in the senate for 36 years
yeah
we're at a point where his legislative
agenda on buildback better and voting
rights act has hit major roadblocks
is there some introspection that his
approach to the senate is not working
and is he are there changes that he's
making to his approach to the senate
given his experience there
well i would also point to his
experience leading him to stay focused
and committed to the bipartisan
infrastructure bill something that many
said could never happen and when it was
voted on 19 republicans voted for it he
leaned on his experience in the senate
to get that done he leaned on his
experience in the senate to get the
american rescue plan done and passed
into law and he will continue to lean on
ascent on his experience in the senate
and as for as a former vice president to
press for voting rights legislation to
press for buildback better and getting
those pieces of legislation done so i
would say uh you know the successes we
had in the past year and that he had
despite the fact that there was a slim
margin uh are actually uh i mean i guess
unbiased but pretty impressive given the
margin we had in the senate and the
challenges we had up against us
given that he's ending his first year
underwater
in the polls americans
more americans disapprove of his
job in office than improve his job in
office what is he planning to do
differently and approach the job in the
in the second year that
shows that he's listening to that
disapproval
well i think what you see in in most of
these polls is a real uh frustration and
exhaustion with covid uh and the fact
that it is not uh over we we share that
we understand that people are fatigued
across the country it's impacting how
they live how they work uh their worries
about their kids their ability to
experience joyful things in life like
concerts and going to restaurants and
seeing friends we understand that
the president knows that the best most
important step he can take is to
continue to fight to get the pandemic
under control uh and also to lower costs
for americans across the country
so i would say it's a continuation of
the fights that he built a great deal of
a base for over the course of the last
year
the disapproval rates are a reflection
of the way he's approached the job
again i would point you to what most
data shows you which is a frustration
about kovid
and prices and and he believes and he's
believed from the beginning that
addressing covet in the economy are
number two one two three four issues and
uh that continues to be the case today
just a couple questions from our
colleagues couldn't be here
do
biden and putin have plans to meet
in the future
i don't have anything to predict for you
on that front as jake mentioned
we're just a force concluding the third
round of talks uh people are going to go
back to their capitals they're going to
discuss and assess
and see where things stand so in terms
of next steps we'll have to see we'll
know more over the coming days
is there a deadline for moscow to
de-escalate in ukraine
again i i'm not going to send any
deadlines here ultimately the choice is
really up to them are they going to
proceed in uh in invading ukraine if so
there are going to be severe
consequences and economic impacts that
will be devastating to the economy
they're long far beyond what happened in
2014 if that's a choice they want to
make and they think that's to their
advantage that's a choice
they they only have the only they have
the power to make that very good thanks
everyone thank you
all right so there is jen saki wrapping
up a press briefing and we are going to
get right to the the latest um the
latest news i saw the super chats coming
in
uh during during the press briefing the
big news here the supreme court court
has blocked joe biden's covet vaccine
mandate for businesses but it will allow
the worker rule for health care workers
um you know we said from the beginning
morally
this is absolutely the right thing to do
will it stand up to court scrutiny and
we did not know the answer we now have
one at least initially the supreme court
today blocked the biden administration
from enforcing its sweeping vaccine or
test requirement for large private
companies but
the conservative majority court allowed
similar requirements to stand for
medical facilities that take medicare or
medicaid payments the osha mandate
required workers at businesses with 100
or more employees must get vaccinated or
submit a negative cova test weekly to
enter the workplace remember fox news
has an even stricter mandate than that
with daily testing um so
you know back when it was hillary versus
trump
and many of us were saying you guys
realize that the supreme court aspect of
the next four years may have incredible
consequences and there were some on the
left who were saying no
hillary and trump are the same if it's
not going to be
who i want then just screw it and let it
be trump
um we are now seeing one of the ways one
of the ways in which that was a disaster
my belief is that had hillary clinton
chosen three supreme court justices
this would stand now that being said it
was always a question whether you could
do this through osha
and uh at a certain point
there is an aspect of opinion here right
there's a reason we call them
conservative or liberal justices even
though we would like to say it's just
the law and there's one interpretation
of the law well then we wouldn't use the
word interpretation and it does make a
difference so that's what's going on now
it's important to remember
businesses can still legally require
vaccinations from
workers or customers
it's the federal government can't
mandate them to do it through osha and
it's a really really important
distinction to make and i hope
i can't tell from what people in the
chat are saying whether people get that
now
obviously you're going to see all these
videos of right-wingers going to
businesses even businesses that don't
have 100 employees anyway understand
that if you have 20 employees
you were never even subject to this but
there's people now you're going to see
the viral videos no the supreme court
ruled you can't do it and it's like okay
actually the supreme court didn't even
rule about anything for under 100 and
the supreme court didn't say a business
can't choose to do this the supreme
court said that
businesses can't be required to do it
through osha
good luck with them understanding that
distinction so that's that's what
happened today
as far as uh as far as the mandate is
concerned
okay um i do want to say thank you to
carol ann miller for signing up on my
website with the coupon code wow 22. i
also want to say thanks to the very edgy
user thick nips dear god for the twitch
prime subscription you were number two
today and i really appreciate that great
day to re-up your twitch prime
subscription or to sign up on my website
we are still banned from facebook
monetization
uh a beautiful thing happened well no so
first a bad thing happened which is one
of our posts was misinterpreted as
anti-vaxx by facebook and we got banned
90 days from monetization it's insane
it's hard to think of a more pro-vaxxed
channel than ours
um
then
five people in our audience who work at
facebook got in touch and said let me
try to get this appealed for you because
this is clearly an algorithmic decision
it's an error okay we're gonna try to
get it fixed five people are working on
it we are on day five of the ban
nothing has happened so far okay so
we're still we're still waiting on that
but
you can sign up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
f facebook that's two fs facebook with
two fs f facebook
to help us make up
what is a nearly 20 percent revenue gap
uh and it's um
it's it's pretty brutal here's an
interesting twitch question why are you
okay with businesses denying service for
certain reasons but not any reason it's
something called the law
there are certain reasons
in the law
that businesses cannot refuse service
those are the ones that i am against
them refusing service for it's called
the law
we live in a society we have a world
as donald trump says um it is against
the law to discriminate on the basis of
an immutable characteristic like
uh national origin
etc
i'm against that that would be breaking
the law
someone saying
we don't want republicans here other
than in washington dc that's legal do i
advocate for it no but what i'm saying
is it's legal
is it legal to require shoes
yes
is it legal to require shirts yes
is it legal to say we want our employees
or customers to show proof of vaccine
yes
that's the law
and what's great about america
is
if you don't like it
you can choose not to go to that
business now obviously they might not
allow you to go anywhere right i mean
that's like sort of the point here they
might say well we're not allowing you in
any way but you can advocate even if
you're vaccinated and you don't like a
vaccine mandate at a restaurant you can
say don't go
don't go to this and then you can ruin
that business financially if enough
people agree with you by saying we're
not going to go
all right
so i don't i don't really know what else
to say it's it's the law is the answer
thanks to kind af
for the twitch prime subscription i
appreciate that okay
we are now getting into some very meaty
thick and rich charges
when whoa what is happening here when it
comes to the trump riots for so this is
so funny actually let me show this to
you
uh i think you guys are going to like
this
uh here it is
brit hume hours ago
hours ago tweeted here's a thought let's
base our view on whether one six was an
insurrection on whether those arrested
are charged with insurrection so far
none has been
what's really funny
is
founder of far right oath keeper militia
group
stuart rhodes
10 others
charged with seditious conspiracy
in the january 6th capital attack um i
tweeted uh earlier
so they were waiting on more serious
charges and actually asha rangapa
weighed in and she says i don't think
they were waiting the more serious
charges are also more complex and take
longer to gather evidence and put
together if you look at the indictment
it is incredibly detailed and you can't
get that info overnight so
three hours and uh brit hume's comment
has been undone
the serious charges are starting to drop
in
oath keepers leader 10 others charged
with seditious conspiracy seditious
conspiracy
um elmer stewart rhodes founder of the
far-right militia group oath keepers
indicted and arrested over his
organization's alleged involvement
planning the 1-6 attacks rhodes is being
charged for the first time in connection
to events leading up to and on january
6th an additional 10 people including
nine others facing separate charges were
also indicted they were charged with
seditious conspiracy
the defendants conspired in a variety of
ways including organizing into teams
that were quote prepared and willing to
use force and to transport firearms and
ammunition into washington dc
more than 700 people now charged
rhode's lawyer told nbc news he was on
the phone with rhodes when the fbi came
to his house to arrest him mosley said
they were talking about his scheduled
appearance before the house committee
when the fbi called rhodes he patched me
in and identified myself as his lawyer
the fbi special agent said they were
outside he needed to come out with his
hands up
hands up these are
extraordinarily serious charges
extraordinarily serious charges
and uh it doesn't seem like it's antifa
it's increasingly looking like it was
not antifa
uh okay
jane says via super chat it's a luxury
to get to choose between a job or a jab
i get to choose between my nervous
system or my life the unvaccinated are
antithetical to freedom
um
very very serious
i want to say thanks to kendall for the
twitch prime subscription you're number
four today also a big thank you to
alexander benkstein who just signed up
using the coupon code f facebook
f facebook oh people are asking what
exactly we were banned for all right let
me show you the offending post this is
just nuts
uh here it is
see if i can put this up on the screen
this is the po look at this
your post didn't follow our community
standards
and it was coverage of alex jones
turning on trump over trump saying
vaccines are good and of course in the
clip we say
the vaccines are good
we say all of the things this got us
banned
for 90 days from facebook monetization
isn't that something
it is really something wild
thanks to joanne stern as well for the
new membership using the code f facebook
i appreciate that also thank you to
nasty
nastynate121 i think it says
um you are number seven today
super chat's coming in why not crowdfund
500 million dollars to bribe sienna and
cinema i guess they mean a mansion to
support the removal of the filibuster
because they're corrupt anyway yeah i i
don't know i mean that that seems like a
pretty wild idea here is video of the
arrest of this oath keeper's seditious
conspiracist but because of the evidence
that they collect in the underlying
investigation they believe they do have
the support based upon the specific
words from some of these these um
alleged co-conspirators that that was in
fact their plan to use violence to
overtake a government
agency or process so to the extent that
it's a
very rare charge it's because it's often
not easy to have the very specific
evidence you would need to prove the
elements of that crime imagine trying to
go home and all of a sudden this is what
you see on your street i mean what what
a situation but now the charges are
getting very very real david asking
about the oath keepers who do they give
an oath to wasn't our constitution hope
it was worth supporting a con man from
queens they'll be bankrupt and possibly
in prison soon yes very much so very
much so uh we do have a hype train going
over on twitch i want to say thanks to
sterling lana for gifting a subscription
that's number eight today very much
appreciate that
um okay let's continue we have a couple
other things to look at
um
this is a wild wild clip
i don't even know if this is new i saw
it today for the first time
herschel walker the republican candidate
told glenn beck that he has a dry mist
that will kill covid
a dry mist that will kill kovad check
out this insanity
that would clean you from covert
crover
it'll kill crover i guess technically
he's not saying it'll kill covid he's
saying it'll kill crover which is maybe
something
drama
different
and you won't
even glenn beck who has refused the
vaccine and now has covered twice
even
even glenn beck isn't sure about this
look at glenn beck's reaction when he
says it'll kill krover
as you walk through the door it will
kill any cover on your body
epa fda approved
when you leave it will kill your eyes as
you leave this product then i have
something you can go and spray down this
product do you know they don't want to
talk about that also if it's mist how is
it dry i don't even understand that it's
like a wet it's like dry water i don't
even know what that means
they don't want to hear about that
i have something a dry mist
a dry mist that would clean you yeah
it's epa and fda approved but they don't
want you to hear about it that's exactly
why is that so hard to imagine
and then i see the disinfectant is there
a way we can do something like that
by
injection inside or
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous uh very powerful light apply
light and heat to cure supposing you
brought the light inside the body right
convalescent plasma
okay
uh so that's that
um
do you guys want to see kamala harris
give a really bad interview like just
it's it's bad it's very very bad
oh thanks to b kimberly for the twitch
prime subscription i appreciate that
um
let me show this to you guys you know
this is just
i don't know if kamala harris was
ill-prepared
this is a really bad interview and i
don't deny for a second
that the biden administration like many
world leaders
are in a really tough position because
of what's going on with omicron but this
is a very bad interview this week we saw
a record number of hospitalizations
adults and children uh we've seen the
infection record broken i think a lot of
people are scratching their heads and
they're wondering one year into this
administration
why why aren't we doing better in the
fight against coving right so let me
start with saying that
people are rightly frustrated with where
we are we're frustrated we're all
frustrated but
i think it's a mistake and it would be a
mistake to suggest that we've not seen
great progress if you think back to
march of 2020
we were all wiping down the boxes that
we got if we ordered things online
there was no vaccine now we have a
vaccine
see here's my take on this question i
obviously what i'm gonna say is
not
focus group tested and i haven't had a
team of pr people tell me
what should be my approach but if i were
her in this situation
when i see the numbers that are going on
i would go listen i think this is craig
melvin from msnbc i would say listen
craig
here's what's going on
the entire world
is overrun with omicron
and with a few very rare exceptions
in
mostly in places that are extremely
authoritarian and where the public
allows a certain level of sort of
government control that would never fly
in most western countries
everybody's being overrun with omicron
and it's happening like clockwork the
peak in south africa
is the same peak we're seeing in the uk
although it's delayed and it looks like
it's the same peak we're seeing in the
united states
it's happening everywhere omicron is
that contagious what we want
is
to protect people from serious illness
and death with the vaccine which it does
and in the meantime get as many tests
out as quickly as possible which was
which the trump administration didn't do
and were doing
and to get people masks which bernie
sanders just suggested
that's what i would say i wouldn't try
to do this you know because when
the their answers
try to justify
a situation
that at the end of the day is the same
basically everywhere to different
degrees and so
that would be my approach and i'm sure
that there are political
analysts that would say david there's a
reason why she wouldn't be advised to
answer in that way because then
i'm just telling you how i would
honestly communicate
that's all i'm saying okay let's
continue
which has proved to be effective and
boosters
now we have our children back in school
95 of schools are back open but we're
we're building back up we're opening
back up and we are not where we were a
year ago let's talk about masks for a
second it's been several weeks now since
public health experts have acknowledged
that cloth masks surgical masks they're
not as effective in in terms of stopping
this new variant omicron should should
americans be wearing k in 95 master and
95 masks
well the cdc is going to be providing us
with those guidelines well what's taking
so long well
the cdc is making their decisions i
don't make the cdc's decisions but what
i will say is what what has been clear
about masks
is you want to wear a tight-fitting mask
that is clear and
it's like at this point
it seems almost
like you're in a fantasy world if you
don't acknowledge there is no
question
that not all masks are created equal
and we are encouraging the cdc to
provide us updated guidance like i feel
like every
single one
of these questions could be better
answered we want to urge everybody to do
that in terms of the n95 masks they are
available there is a stockpile of i
believe over 700 million of those masks
so the supply is there as necessary and
as needed at what point does the
administration say you know what the
strategy isn't working we're going to
change strategies
six former
administration officials last week wrote
that open letter urging the
administration to change course to
change strategy
is it time
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
that is not good that is not am i being
too hard on her guys this is really bad
it's like
the the again this is where she could
say
we are in a situation right now with the
variant that is so contagious so
contagious and so widespread
that what we need to be doing
is getting as many people boosted
because that prevents you from getting
seriously ill
protect people as much as we can
it's going down in south africa it's
down 65 percent
it's down in the uk
we have wastewater data from boston and
other places that show it's starting to
go down here
this now is like it's just weird let we
have to keep doing everything
i don't know guys i don't know
every day it is time for us to
agree
that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
and so right now we know we still have
a number of people that that is in the
millions of americans who have not been
vaccinated
and could be vaccinated and we are
urging them to get vaccinated because it
will save their life at what point does
the administration acknowledge these
people
aren't going to get the shot they're
just not going to do it i don't believe
in giving up on people craig i really
don't the 500 million times see again
it's not about giving up on people
it's having a strategy that doesn't
depend on those people and these are two
different things tests that have been
ordered that are going to be sent to
every every american do we know when
those are going out
shortly though they're going to go out
early
the tests are going out this is maybe
the worst part the tests are going out
shortly they've been ordered we i have
to look at the current information i
think it's going to be by next week but
soon absolutely soon and it is a matter
of urgency for us should we have done
that sooner
we are doing it
again
you know should we have done it sooner
i can understand why she wouldn't say
yes
i can understand that i can understand
why a political apparatus would say you
can't say yet you can't give a simple
yes
you can't give a simple yes
but
we are doing it
and by the way everyone's saying other
people's interviews were worse
we're looking at this interview right
now i've covered other interviews as
well i'm not saying this is the worst
interview it's just not good she's not
coming off well in this interview i
still voted for biden guys come on
um
just repeating we are doing it
it's not great but should we have done
it soon we are doing it let's turn the
voting rights here for a moment um you
were there in atlanta with the president
um when he
uh compared those who oppose
uh democratic-backed voting bills that
are currently in the senate he compared
the folks who oppose those to i don't
think so i see that someone's saying
that that craig melvin's asking bad bad
questions no these are these are real
questions these are real questions you
look at the numbers and it's crazy
should we be doing something different
she could answer and say this is so
contagious that it what we're seeing
from other countries is it almost
doesn't matter what you do in terms of
cases
what matters is in terms of keeping
people out of the hospital that would be
a fair answer
i think these are this is called this is
called journalism this is asking
questions folks who oppose civil rights
senator romney in response yesterday he
took to the floor of the senate and he
said quote so much for unifying the
country
when the president was on the campaign
trail in the fall of 2020 he said
something he said with trump out of the
way the vindictiveness of a president
going after republicans by the way i
don't know what's worse kamala's answers
or the jump cuts in the editing that was
chosen for this interview it's bizarre
don't do exactly what he says gets taken
away
isn't that exactly what what president
biden did in atlanta on wednesday
president biden
took the i believe
right and courageous
step
to say
that
senate rules should not get in the way
of protecting
the american people's access to the
ballot
and
he compared this time
to a previous time in our history
which is apt for comparison it's not
just republican opposition it would seem
as if this piece of legislation is going
to come down to one or two
moderate democrats all right so the the
the really bad part was about this part
is just kind of completely milk toast
but the really bad part was was about
covid and so you know as many of you
know
i have said a number of times now
i
would be very worried about if biden
runs again biden versus trump 2024 i'm
not feeling great about biden
biden versus desantis 2024 i'm not
feeling great about biden if biden says
i'm not running for reelection
and we are kind of saying it's going to
be kamala if if however it is kamala is
the nominee and it's kamala versus trump
i'm not feeling very good about it and
if it's kamala versus desantis i'm also
not feeling very good about it people
can people can argue with me
um it's just my opinion you all know i
mean it's i just i just call it like it
is and it's uh
it's a concern i want to say thank you
to prickly sausage
for signing up via twitch prime i really
appreciate that remember that if you
have amazon prime you can get a free
twitch prime membership you take a few
bucks from jeff bezos and you give them
to us and it costs you nothing and we
really really appreciate it i also want
to say thanks to gerardo i have a cousin
gerardo gerardo
now i don't know if this is supposed to
be oh cardozo perez well thanks to
gerardo for signing up on my website
with the coupon code f
facebook f facebook let me play for you
guys a really ugly voicemail that i
received
um it is
uh a pretty brutal voicemail but i am
going to play it for you take a listen
i've just seen you on the
table television this morning
um you're a real piece of [ __ ] you know
that right
people like you is what's tearing this
country apart
that i disagree with
you're a podcast white boy that i
disagree with i am hispanic
i am hispanic
white hispanic but actually you know
what's really funny about that
obviously i'm white passing
in the united states i moved to the u.s
early enough that i don't have an accent
in english
um
except when i talk about the horror
of situations
uh but that's not even an accent from
argentina anyway um
white supremacists are like no no no
you're not white you're jewish
but then on the left they're like oh
yeah you're right
uh cause jews are privileged
and um
anyway okay let's continue i got your
ass flipped a whole bunch back in the
day you you just no that's not true no
so liberal it's not even [ __ ] funny
your disgrace
you go [ __ ] whoa
interesting i think if it was that
caller versus kamala i i feel good about
kamala in that that matchup for sure
i want to say thanks to last throw
gen here and splooging unicorn for the
twitch prime subscriptions those are
numbers 12
13
and 14.
uh very very much appreciate that
um ryan ferguson says i was sitting in
my room the other night and i realized
my spouse was gone i heard a strange
sound outside there was a knock on the
door and the man said sir your wife is
up in the air that is something
that is really really something that
sounds like a stressful stressful thing
okay so we got that we did the herschel
walker thing oh the other day i jokingly
when i banned someone i said
get off my stream and it was a reference
to the movie air force one someone
actually did that
uh replacing harrison ford's face with
my face in that scene and uh very very
nicely done wait let's see here here it
is
that's nicely done i like that
that's pretty funny
so i appreciate that
uh okay we're back over here
oh thank you to judo known
for the twitch prime subscription i
appreciate that what time are we
starting on saturday okay so here's my
thought about saturday officially
speaking
uh donald trump is scheduled to speak at
9 00 pm eastern saturday at the arizona
rally
my plan is to start streaming an hour
before that at 8 00 pm eastern
and an hour of pre pre-rally stuff is
fine
the truth is trump typically comes on so
late that we'll probably get closer to
90 minutes so my thought if it's okay
with you guys is to start streaming at 8
pm eastern on saturday and we might be
able to catch pillow pillow is expected
to speak
and um
yeah i'll just play an hour of whitney's
voicemails and we'll it'll it'll go
it'll fly it'll fly by no and the other
thing if people are interested i was
gonna refresh the trump bingo
for we used to have trump let me see if
i actually have it
uh let me see
bingo oh boy hold on that did not sound
good where is my bingo element
soundboard
um
i think i've got to make it from scratch
yeah i was going to refresh trump bingo
so that we could just have a new version
of it and and play to just to have
something to kind of keep our sanity if
you guys think that that would be uh
that that would be appropriate and i'll
have that put together for everybody by
um
by saturday for the rally
um
will trump say obama that's a really
good question yeah that's i don't know
whether he will
remember this guys
if ted doesn't win your second amendment
is going to be in trouble big trouble
remember that
o'rourke voted against the border wall
oh that's a good thing to him he voted
against kate's law and he voted for
obama
amnesty
amnesty obama
what does it mean to vote against case
law like what i don't even really
understand the meaning of that it's a
very very strange thing to say
okay couple voicemails yeah let's do it
we haven't done voicemails for a while i
do have some new uh uh weaponized
disinformation from eric from mass hey
david eric from math straight from the
cdc 78 percent of cover deaths among
vaccinated at four plus comorbidities so
cut the 800 000
let's round it off to eighty percent
that's four five uh
it's about a hundred and
forty thousand or so hundred and thirty
thousand
uh
no pandemic buddy
or more co-morbidities that means
stuff like that and things like that
nature and
means the normal person the regular
healthy person
only about 100 plus thousands even eric
sounds bored of his own phone calls
do you know how many of the 836 000
deaths in the u.s linked to copays are
from copenhagen that sounds like is that
bret bayer it sounds like he's playing
brett bayer through the phone
which is an odd thing to do for sure
let me see what else we've got here
the voicemail has been particularly
trash lately
um
here's jimmy from philly
save it get me from philly what
so
dr oz really scares you doesn't he
if you ever ran for office david i call
you dr propaganda
i don't claim to be a doctor
that's the weird thing
mr david pakman uh i'm calling by the
video about president trump um the real
president
and his interview all right well we're
off of that
uh he left a bunch more but not not
super interested right now
um
let's see
what else i have that might be of
interest for you
um
oh here's something from the eggman
hi dave and pat this is a very serious
question my wife and kids are vegetarian
slash vegan even um and they say stuff
like animals should never be used for
clothing for entertainment for food
stuff like that right um pig heart man i
just want to say that um i'm not that
upset with pig heart man i think it's
okay to use that pig part to extend this
man's life so i'd ask you this are they
making bacon out of the rest of that pig
and if so would pat eat that bacon or
dave would you eat that bacon and i
asked you this because this animal is
being used for medical purposes to save
a man's life and you don't want that
bacon going to waste do you you wouldn't
like throw out no i wouldn't have it
anyway because bacon is a carcinogen
so it doesn't yeah i would not have the
bacon
um
yeah
wow something is really going on with
our collars these days
let's see um
here's another jimmy from philly david
jimmy from philly so since january and
february are bad months for creators i
personally think you pushed the limits
on the facebook thing so you could get
more membership
yeah david that's what you did you prick
oof uh that's an insane thing to say
um
let me see what else i got
uh do i have anything else of interest
for you guys oh we haven't heard
anything from whitney so let's hear from
whitney
so i noticed everybody's having an issue
with the presidentism
and i feel like i'm having like with
what what did she say
people are having an issue did anybody
understand that
an issue with what
the presidency
prejudicism
let me listen once more hold on
so i noticed everybody's having an issue
with the presidentism
i think she says
prejudice-ism yeah i think that is what
it is and i feel like i'm having like
the most amount of issue with it
um just because i really really saw
into
like what
like most people in the black community
wanted from the white people and like
wanted them to say because i do
really really care obviously when it's
like
you know a lot of my life i've been told
like i'm not perfect
and
you and me both whitney you know
you want to figure out how to be perfect
well i don't know that that's real is
that really anyone's goal
to be perfect
i don't know
seems like an unrealistic goal
that you can succeed in the world and
not have people like you know just
dumping their [ __ ] on you all the time
and
like i realized like with the jewish
people there's like a line that you
don't cross
oh and
what i noticed is that a lot of my
comments are actually
more anti-semitic yes whitney i've
noticed the same thing
uh we are against anti-semitism just in
the interest of full disclosure of for
everybody on you know facebook youtube
and twitch we are against anti-semitism
but i i uh commend whitney
a lot of your comments are very
anti-semitic and i'm glad that that
you're recognizing that i want to say
thank you to weslow
dying in chat and the teal appeal for
the twitch prime subscriptions i also
want to thank sandra ferguson for the
website membership sandra just signed up
at joinpackman.com
using the coupon code wow 22
wow 22. all right that is everything i
have for today we'll be back tomorrow
with a new show podcast clips all of it
and then saturday i hope you'll join me
at 8 pm eastern
for the pillow trump rally
in florence
or florence arizona
i can only imagine it will be a
disgusting display
a disgust sorry a disgusting display of
all of the worst
of the worst
of american society uh we'll see
everybody then thank you